New York City a region of many names and
a gateway to the USA the New York City
area prior to the European colonization
was for thousands of years inhabited by
the monopoly people who spoke in onami
language which is a subgroup of the
Algonquin language these people used the
vast waterways of the area for fishing
trade and later on even agriculture
using the slash-and-burn method to clear
land we don't know much about their
lifestyle prior to the European arrival
as they had no written language and
archaeology can only go so far but we do
know that by the time of European
arrival there were around 5,000 Lonavala
living in about 80 settlements around
the New York City area the first of
these Europeans to arrive in 1524 was an
Italian Explorer that was one of the
survivors of the Magellan
circumnavigation of the globe Giovanni
da Verrazzano he was employed by the
French government to find that pesky
Western passage to the Pacific and while
on this voyage he stumbled upon the new
york bay area which he named new uncle
in honor of france and its king for
about the next hundred years after him
the area became somewhat of a back-alley
fur trade secret where free traders
would occasionally show up to trade with
the local natives then in 1609 an
Englishman Henry Hudson employed by the
Dutch East India Company sailed into the
New York Bay and up the Hudson River
again in search of that Western Passage
he obviously didn't find it however he
did send back reports of an abundance of
beavers which were the backbone of the
lucrative fur trade the Dutch you're
looking to capitalize on this newfound
resource established a fur trading camp
in lower Manhattan the area quickly
proved to be strategically important and
a year later the construction of Fort
Amsterdam began the small trading cam
now started to grow in size around the
fort the whole town started to be called
near Amsterdam and became the most
influential city in the Dutch colony of
New Netherlands New Amsterdam just as
almost every European colony in the
Americas was in constant warfare with
the surrounding natives Hauer due to
superior technology the Dutch won easily
almost every encounter it was at that
same time that due to a lack of labor
force in the growing City Dutch
merchants start to import African slaves
which numbered almost 20% of the city's
population in 1660 for that same year
the English conquered the area of New
Netherlands including near Amsterdam but
the Dutch managed to briefly retake the
city in 1675
or Union a new name for some reason new
orange they then proceeded to secede the
entire new Netherlands to the British in
favor of the more prosperous colony at
the time Suriname
under the British the city got renamed
to New York after the Duke of York in
England New York City now part of the
prosperous British Empire started to
grow ever more rapidly completely
pushing out the Native Americans from
the surrounding area many new British
colonists started coming to the city and
what emerged as a fur trading outpost
started to become more of an
administrative slush transshipment hub
more slaves were also brought in from
Africa and the Caribbean to serve the
ever-growing population how are also
more slaves started to be freed so the
percentage of slave population by 1740
didn't really change remaining at 20%
1754 King George ii founded a Kings
College in New York later renamed the
Columbia University which was one of the
only nine colleges founded in the USA
prior to the Revolution when the Stamp
Act was started used to tax the colonies
so Britain could pay off the debts from
the costly French and Indian War
American revolutionary ideas started to
flow around the colonies and even though
in New York there were Sons of Liberty
who fought over symbolically really
posts with the law enforcement the
city's population overall weren't big
fans of the idea of the Revolution and
when the revolution started this by the
city had started being in American hands
after three quick defeat from the
Continental Army the city was captured
by the British and remained the most
significant loyal a stronghold for the
rest of the war the city became the
military and operation center for the
British activities in north and USA
which naturally prompted the city to be
in the midst of an espionage battle
between the loyalists and the
revolutionaries there were also a few
fires a very dubious origin that were
started in the city which forced many
residents to live in makeshift tents or
on board of anchored British vessels
these British vessels were also used as
prison ships for captured
revolutionaries and due to poor
conditions on board more Americans died
in these ships than in the war itself as
the Revolutionary War was coming to an
end a large influx of refugees started
to pour into the city this influx was so
high that in 1783 the British had to
postpone the final date of withdrawal
from the city just so they could
accommodate all these refugees in
and well over 32,000 people who are
evacuated here back to Britain or other
British controlled colonies post-war in
New York City even though not the
largest city at the time which was
Philadelphia for a brief moment became
the most significant city in the USA in
1785 the congressman in the city under
the Articles of Confederation and four
years later the city became the first
capital of the United States under the
new constitution the center point of all
these new changes was the federal hall
on Wall Street it was where the US
Congress and Supreme Court said it was
the place where George Washington got
inaugurated as president and also was
the place where the Bill of Rights was
drafted and ratified but in 1790 the
Capitol was officially changed to
Philadelphia and New York City's brief
flirt with politics was over now free of
politics the city became quickly
occupied by business trade and industry
the two major changes that brought about
drastic development to the city was the
commissioners plan of 1811 which
increased the size of New York City's
grid system
all while encompassing the entire
Manhattan area and the 1825 construction
of the Erie Canal connecting Midwest
United States and Canada to the Atlantic
trade routes the latter of which proved
to be extremely significant to the
city's success as it was located in the
midst of the trade between north and USA
and the rest of the world therefore
unsurprisingly ten years later New York
City surpassed Philadelphia as the most
populous city in the USA a title which
holds to this day for the next ten years
New York City's economy continued to
grow and aforementioned ideal location
due to the Erie Canal made it a perfect
hub for not just trade goods but also
immigrants lots of immigrants coming
into the u.s. passed through New York
City as it was easy for them to not just
find work in the city but also travel
onward to Cleveland Detroit Chicago etc
New York City at this point truly became
the Gateway to the American
industrializing heartland and no other
events who planted this idea more than
the Irish potato famine
millions of people deprived of food and
Ireland had to migrate to other places
often times choosing New York City as
the main destination in fact the influx
of Irish immigrants to the city was so
drastic that by the 1850 one quarter of
the population was of Irish descent is
drastically increasing population in the
city sparked the foundation of the NYPD
NYC do e and
to political prominence of the Tammany
Hall but more on that later during the
1850s the old merchant class of the city
pushed ours the creation of a central
park which was approved in 1857 and
construction began the following year
Howard wouldn't be fully finished to its
current form until 1873 during that
period the US would undergo a huge
change in the form of the American Civil
War this proved to be very problematic
for the city as half of its exports
before the war was one way or another
connected to a constant supply of cotton
from the south as such the economy of
the city became very strained and the
continuous flow of immigrants started to
cause major issues as they weren't happy
about conscription almost right off of
the book that document makes you a
citizen this one makes your private in
the Union Army now go fight for your
country next all these stresses in the
city culminated in the 1863 draft riots
which mostly targeted African Americans
as they were seen as the problem for the
city's troubles the war eventually ended
in 1865 and with that the city's economy
came back on track with a new but also
will establish power in the city started
to gain more traction this power being
the New York Stock Exchange which in
1865 already operated from its current
location on Wall Street the organization
which would become the NYC can be traced
to just twenty four stockbrokers who
signed a bottom with agreement which was
a first attempt at organizing securities
trading in 1792 from there the
organization grew with the city and as
New York became the largest city in the
USA both by trade and population the now
renamed New York Stock Exchange
overshadowed any neighboring cities
attempt at securities trading eventually
becoming the primary Stock Exchange of
the whole country
financially and economically the city
was booming but so was the emigration to
the city which did not slow down and
many European immigrants continued to
stay in the city giving even more power
to the aforementioned Toumani Hall now
if you never heard of tamati Hall it was
a powerful political institution that
ran or at least drastically influenced
New York State and especially City for
almost a century it was a so-called
Democratic Party political machine that
gained most of its influence through
helping
immigrants assimilate into the new world
most notably the Irish but also many
others the term Annie Hall rang
countless construction projects and
welfare institutions and as such it was
liked by the immigrant lower-class
however it was also praised by the New
York City's business class as his
members were known to make quick
reactionary decisions to changing
markets and seldom cared for much red
tape but another may be more important
reason why the business class liked
Amani was because it was unfamous Lee
bribable and this embedded corruption
within the organization combined with
the Great Depression and then trying to
pick a fight with FDR eventually led to
the Tammany Hall downfall by the 1950s
going back to the 1880s to early work on
the Statue of Liberty has already
started by Frederic Auguste Bartholdi
and supported by many organizations
including the French government the
money for the project was mostly gotten
by fundraising in various areas like
showing the hand in Central Park or the
head at the Paris World's Fair etc but
even with all that funds for the full
projects were lacking in New York City
and other cities like Philadelphia or
Boston offered to pay the whole price of
the Statue were to be relocated to Derry
City New Yorkers not to be admitted by
some other city created a huge drive
through the New York world newspaper and
managed to raise enough funds to make
sure that the statute would be negated
to the world in New York City in 1886
October 28th as the dedication parade
for the Statue passed next to the New
York Stock Exchange traders started to
throw actual ticker tape down onto the
streets beginning the now well-known
practice of ticker tape parades going
into the 20th century NYC was in a city
in the USA it was D City Indy USA first
modern NYC we know today was created by
consolidating the five well-known
boroughs the first New York City subway
company emerged many new construction
projects went underway and the city's
economy was again on the rise the boom
was slightly slowed down by the outbreak
of World War one however due to the
fairly short US involvement in the Great
War the city's economy wasn't that
drastically affected after the war going
into the roaring 20s the city had
certain problems the never ending
incoming emigration now combined with a
large influx of internal migrants meant
that New York City for a brief moment
became
most populated city in the world in 1925
but with that came the countless
infrastructure problems increase in
crime and poverty etc all these problems
happening under the noses of the city's
higher class enjoying record high stock
prices lavish speakeasies and parties
but the bubble had to pop someday and so
it did on 29th of October 1929 a day
known as black Tuesday when the New York
City stock market crashed David wasn't
solely responsible for the Great
Depression but it did pave the way for
its start New York City during this time
struggled just as any other city in the
USA with unemployment rate being the
highest in history combate this many
immigration restriction acts were
created during this time hoping that the
slow down immigration will help the
unemployment rate of the citizens but
this turned out not to be the case and
the Great Depression progressed
surprisingly despite all of this
happening some of the most iconic
skyscrapers were built in the city
during this era such as the Chrysler
Building the Empire State Building
Rockefeller Center etc nonetheless the
Great Depression continued and after the
12 long years of struggle the World War
two started even though the conflict
itself so many deaths the war proved
extremely valuable to the US economy and
as such New York City was back on track
expanding and developing this time
however not focused around industry
anymore
many dock yards and factories were
closed and replaced by the service
financial and world trading industries
there was a time of great growth but
again not for all for example Bronx
borough experienced a sharp decline in
this era they're gonna pre-war period
Bronx house middle to moderate income
classes Howard to start to change to
mostly lower class income poverty and
violent crimes were common in the area
and the infrastructure was not on par
compared to other regions mostly due to
the fact that minorities lived there all
these problems were an exclusive to just
Bronx borough and by the 1970s most of
the city gained a reputation as a crime
riddled relic of history
distant culminated in 1975 when New York
City the financial capital of the USA
almost had to file for bankruptcy only
to be saved by debt restructuring and
federal loans thankfully this low point
meant that NYC had nowhere to go but up
and so it did struggling areas like
Bronx experienced the resurgence and
development
and construction of new infrastructure
projects Wall Street regained most of
its ground lost into ADEs crashes and
New York City overall remained the
largest city / metropolitan area in the
United States New York today is well New
York no no no you can't end a video like
that yes I can no you can't a good
ending has to have a concise summary of
the video and a hopeful message
applicable to today's city and its
future cadence Ponte pants you do it
gladly New York City started off as a
humble Dutch fur trading outpost only to
grow to be one of the richest cities in
the world it saw its fair share of
battles hardships dangers and more
remaining strong through all of it while
trading with the world and serving as a
gateway to North America when the going
gets tough in New York City the tough
gets going and therefore today the city
continues to be the country's largest
financial commercial and Information
Center and it's not showing any signs of
stopping in the near future by the way
if you like this video you might want to
check out a video over at my channel
that talks about the similarities and
differences of New York City and Los
Angeles yeah you should definitely go
check it out and thank you to mr. beat
for helping me at the end of this video
no problem for those of you who came
from the mr. beat video let me put you
to one of my videos algorithmically
picked by YouTube to be the most likely
to interest you whether that'll be the
case or not I have no idea
so anyways please consider subscribing
and supporting me on patreon my name is
Sam laser and see you next time